Our office is awesome,...
...but not everyone is there every day.
Some people might never be there.
And when you're not at the office, it can feel like you're missing out...
...on the energy and spontaneous conversations.
Check this out.
So how do we work together like we're all at the office?
How do you guys feel about the website?
It looks pretty good.
Tandem spaces, that's how.
Oh, hey there.
Love that mug.
Thank you, I made it actually.
Really into pottery.
Think of Tandem spaces like a window into the office,...
...an open window where your remote team could work,...
...hang out and join in just like they're there.
Hey, let me show you this mock-up.
Oh, let me see.
We're thinking that this part can be completely interactive.
Hey, I love that.
See, it could rotate like this.
Hey, just jumping in to say, number one, I think that's awesome,...
...and two, we can definitely pull that off.
I'll let the team know.
I got you.
They're right here.
Hey, what's up?
Just talked to the design team and check this out.
That looks awesome.
Can we add layers to it too?
Yeah, we can add labels.
With Tandem spaces, I can move around and find my team.
And I could join a meeting in the conference room,...
...brainstorm with my team over here...
...and see Mike, who's about to drop his new mug on the ground.
Mike!
Thank you.
With Tandem spaces, we can work like we're in the same room...
...no matter where we are.